حكيم مقاطعتي خاركيف الاوكرانيه بمقتل
اربعه مدنيين واصابه اخرين في قصف روسي
مكثف على المقاطعه الحدوديه مع روسيا في
غضون ذلك قال حاكم مقاطعه بالقرود الروسيه
اثنين اصيب بجروح خطره خلال تجدد للقصف
الاوكراني على بلده شبكين الحدوديه مع
اوكرانيا وكشف ان السلطات قررت وقف حركه
القطارات والسيارات باتجاه البلده حتى 30
من الشهر الجاري بسبب استمرار القصف على
البلدات الحدوديه
هي ينضم الينا من هناك مراسل الجزيره
امينه درغامي امين كيف يبدو الوضع بعد
تجدد القصف هناك كما تقول روسيا وما هي
خططها للتعامل مع التوالي وتواصل الهجوم
على منطقه
نعم تحيه طيبه سهام حاكم مقاطعه بيلغرود
اعلن اليوم عن سقوط مدنيين اثنين
اصيب بعد تجدد القصف على بلده شبيكنو التي
تشهد قصفا متواصلا من الجانب الاوكراني
بحسب السلطات الروسيه منذ ايام وتحديدا
منذ اكثر من اسبوع حاكم المقاطعه اكد ايضا
ان حده القصف هذا الصباح تراجعت في شبيكنا
ولكنه اقال بان بلده
المجاوره ما زالت تشهد قصفا متقطعا ما ادى
الى اغلاق تلك المنطقه الحدوديه مع
اوكرانيا ووقف جميع الطرق المؤديه اليها
من سكك الحديد وايضا الطرق الى غايه
الثلاثين من هذا شارفي اجراء اتخذته
السلطات المحليه للتعامل مع هذا قصف
المتوالي وايضا مع محاولات
المجموعات الاوكرانيه التابعه للجيش
الاوكراني من الدخول الى المنطقه عبر
الحدود كما جرى الحال عليه الاسبوع الماضي
ايضا عمليه اجلاء المدنيين من شبيكنو
بالتحديد ما زالت متواصله اليوم قال بان
هذه العمليه ستتواصل واعلن عن ارسال اكثر
من 300 او عفوا 600 مدني الى مقاطعتي
كالوجا وايضا القريبتين من العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو بعد الاتفاق مع حكيمي تلك
المقاطعتين الروسيتين هنا في مدينه
صباح اليوم والليله الماضيه اعترضت
الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه اهدافا فوق سماء
المدينه هذا الخبر اكده اليوم ايضا صباحا
حاكم المقاطعه
ومواقع روسيه قالت بان
حطام لطائره مسيره سقط على بنايه او منزل
سكني قربه مدينه
بيل جورد الاوضاع هنا مازالت متوتره عمليه
الاجلاء ممازله انشئ في المدينه قبل يومين
مقر
يعني ايواء النازحين من مدينه شبيكنا
والقرى